Hi guys i'm Abbey Sharp and welcome to
Abbey's Kitchen! We are back today with
the Ridiculist and for my long-term
followers you know it has been a while,
but this one is worth the wait because
we've got a special COVID19 edition.
Now, it's no question that we have all been
bombarded with a stream of coronavirus
related information for the past several
weeks, whether it's the growing number of
statistics worldwide, the necessary
safety precautions, or the implementation
of new policies to protect the public.
While all super valuable, it has been a
lot to process so I do hope you're all
hanging in there and staying safe
through these uncertain times. But of
course along with this valid information
comes a lot of misinformation and
predatory marketing that you know this
girl will not have. Obviously, one of the
major culprits of this misinformation
have come from wellness influencers and
companies trying to sell or promote
immunity boosting products that claim to
specifically protect against or treat
COVID 19. Insert eye roll here. Now before
we even get into it I want to start by
strongly emphasizing that there is no
one miracle food, tincture, tea, or
over-the-counter product on the market
right now that can prevent against or
treat infection from COVID 19. Yes,
ensuring we're getting enough sleep,
minimizing stress, and eating a diet rich
in antioxidant rich fruits and
vegetables can generally support a
healthy immune system but they don't
undo bad hygiene and even healthy people
with healthy immune systems are getting
sick. This is a highly contagious virus
so until we have a regulated vaccine
available to the public, the only thing
that can protect you from infection are
the recommendations that have been
outlined by health authorities worldwide.
So those include number one - good hand
hygiene which means washing your hands
for 20 seconds with soap and water,
especially after touching surfaces or
being in public.
Number 2 - avoiding touching your face,
mouth, eyes, and nose. Three - coughing or
sneezing into your elbow. And four -
most importantly practicing social
distancing which means staying home as
much as possible to prevent possible
infection and further spread of the
virus. And no this does not mean popping
in to your friend's house for a little
coffee date or a wine night and it
certainly doesn't mean meeting up with
your family for dinner or a cute little
movie night. Social distancing means parking
your butt and staying the eff home. Now
before we get into it my general
disclaimer that the information in this
video is for education and entertainment
purposes only and you should always seek
the help of a medical professional for
any COVID 19 treatment. Okay whoo let's
do this.
Glad I wore my sassy pants today. So
first up on the ridiculist,
the "corona virus protocol" by Herbal Amy.
Talk about taking advantage of
vulnerable people in desperate times.
This protocol claims to prevent and
treat infection through a combination of
a number of different tinctures, teas, and
oils, including a corona virus boneset tea, coronavirus cell protection,
coronavirus core tincture, corona virus
immune system, and an elderberry tincture.
Whoo that was a mouthful. Now all of
these products are being sold for the
hefty price of a $155 dollars. Yes, $155 USD.
Now the website claims that the herbs
possess powerful antiviral properties to
kill corona viruses, it also claims that
the formulas are preventative as well as
specific for acute infections from the
corona virus. Really Amy? Really??
Now the active ingredients in these products which include elderberry, skullcap, and
Japanese knotweed, have been used in
natural medicine for centuries for their
antiviral properties. And while there is
some research to suggest that elderberry
may help treat the flu, and skullcap and
Japanese knotweed may have
anti-inflammatory properties, they have
not been tested or proven to do anything
with this deadly virus. In fact, some
experts worry that because of
elderberries immune activating properties
it might actually make the illness,
if contracted, more aggressive. Again, we
don't really know. But more
problematically however, is that these
products, particularly the skullcap and
the knotweed, may have adverse side
effects including liver damage. Skullcap
may also cause lung complications,
irregular heartbeat, and mental confusion
in some people. So be sure to speak to
your doctor before taking any of these
kinds of products. The shadiest part of
this protocol is the fact that the hand
sanitizer doesn't even contain any
alcohol. Which is probably because
alcohol is seen as a toxin in a lot of
wellness communities but here's a little
insider tip - we kind of need toxins to
kill viruses and hand sanitizer needs
to be at least 60% ethanol or 70% isopropyl to even be effective.
I'm kind of shocked and honestly a
little offended that enough people spend
a $155 on this thing to have to have this protocol sell out!
But hey! It's your money, it's your
life. Next! Okay next up on the ridiculist
is boneset tea by Vivify Holistic Clinic.
So this holistic clinic in Sarnia, Canada
promoted the use of Boneset tea for the
treatment of coronavirus infection
citing alleged findings by Stephen
Buhner, an author and herbalist.
Now Buhner claims to have done extensive
research on corona viruses and has
supposedly treated them successfully
with boneset tea but this research is
not something I would even call research.
He mostly just cites his own books on
herbalist while providing no real
literature to back up his
sensationalized claims. So before it was
taken down, the website recommended
drinking this special tea six times daily
to treat an active infection. Tea?
For coronavirus? This grossly problematic
suggestion has since been removed and
replaced with a note that there are no
claims being made to cure any medical
condition and to seek treatment from your
Doctor. A plus on the disclaimer, but would
have been great to see that in the first
place before they got called out by the
FDA. As for the tea itself, boneset has
been traditionally used as an herbal
remedy to treat things like influenza,
the common cold, joint pain, fever,
pneumonia, and other conditions and there
is even some early research to suggest
that taking Boneset tea may reduce
symptoms of the common cold. But this was
a study done with 53 people and it was
on the cold and it has become very clear
that COVID 19 is no cold. Ingesting Boneset tea may also come with some risks
including severe diarrhea and vomiting.
It also contains chemicals called
pyrrolizidine alkaloids which have been
known to cause liver damage. I don't see
a disclaimer about that on the site Mr.
Buhner. Thankfully, the FDA recently
classified Boneset as an herb of
unidentified safety because we really
don't know if it's even safe to use
period, never mind as a remedy for a
deadly virus. The last thing we need to
be dealing with right now is the
potential risks that come with drinking
excessive amounts of diarrhea tea.
So save your money, stay properly hydrated, and follow the advice of medical
professionals. Next! Okay moving on to
colloidal silver. Now I have seen a lot
of companies peddling the use of
colloidal silver for the treatment of
corona virus. This includes The Jim
Bakker Show,  Vital Silver, JRB Enterprise
group, and the company called Xephyr N-Ergetics. Now The Jim Bakker Show aired
a segment promoting the sale of
colloidal silver for a $125 a bottle.
Now on the show, naturopathic doctor Sherril Sellmen
claimed that even though colloidal
silver hasn't been tested on COVID 19, it
has been used with other corona viruses
and has been able to eliminate it within
12 hours. Umm I'd like to see your reference for that. Similarly, one company
Vital Silver recommends taking two
spoons of colloidal silver twice daily
to kill the virus as they state the
silver will attach to the virus
rendering them ineffective and boosting
your immune system. That is quite the
claim. If colloidal silver were really
the saving grace of the corona virus,
then I'm pretty sure we wouldn't all be
living in a global pandemic right now
with valuable health care workers
getting violently ill. To give you a
brief background on what colloidal
silver even is, it's basically a mineral
often used as a homeopathic remedy to
treat bacterial, viral, and fungal
infections. The exact mechanism behind
this is not fully understood, mostly
because there's no research to support
these claims but proponents of colloidal
silver claim that it can bind to
bacterial or viral cells and damage
their cell walls and DNA resulting in
cell death. Not surprisingly, the evidence
on this is seriously lacking. In fact,
colloidal silver has no known function
in the body at all and is not even
considered an essential mineral to begin
with. There's also been concerns raised
by the safety and risks of ingesting
colloidal silver as exposure can lead to
the development of something called
argyria which is a condition that turns
the skin a blue gray color as a result
of the buildup of silver particles in
the skin and other organs like the liver,
kidneys, and intestines. So not only is
colloidal silver ineffective at treating
any bacterial or viral infection,
including COVID 19, but it may also make
you turn blue. I don't think any of us
are trying to turn into the blueberry
girl from Willy Wonka. Colloidal silver, I
am taking a hard pass. Next!
Alright, next up on the chopping block is none other than the power of essential oils.
Now, I am all for a nice smelling home
but at this point a house that reeks of
bleach is probably better protected from
coronavirus than one that smells of
diffused lavender and sage. Using
essential oils to treat and prevent
coronavirus has been recently promoted
by companies like Gurunanda and
Quinessence Aromatherapy.
Gurunanda, specifically, was promoting the
sale of tea tree and eucalyptus oils as
a means to target COVID 19. On their
website they stated that essential oils
have great potential in the field of
biomedicine,
as they effectively destroy bacterial,
fungal, and viral pathogens. By using
these essential oils, the company
promises to decrease the chances of
becoming infected with corona virus and
even offers a 50% discount on essential
oil products by using the promo code
CORONA. Really? I am generally annoyed
with oil peddlers suggesting that you'll
lose 10 pounds after sniffing ginger but
this is next-level bad. Now Quinessence
Aromatherapy on the other hand claims
that a wide range of essential oils have
been clinically proven to possess
antiviral properties and have measurable
effects on infections including
influenza. On their website they have
also stated that since this new strain
of virus continues to be a very serious
threat right now, it certainly can't hurt
to use essential oils that you already
have to avoid infection until a cure has
been developed. Uh I agree, I mean it
certainly can't hurt but don't tell
people that it's going to help them
avoid infection. Ballsy huh? What we do
know about essential oils is that they
have long been used in aromatherapy as a
form of alternative medicine to support
general health and well-being. There are
over 90 commonly used essential oils
each with their own associated health
claims with variable levels of efficacy.
While I personally love the smell of
lavender oil in my bath before bed and I
have no problem with people using them
therapeutically if it brings them joy,
I would never rely on any oil to combat
this serious novel virus and I would
hope that any reputable oil company or
representative wouldn't recommend people
do that. So friends, if you want to cover
up the smell of disinfectant wipes
lingering on your countertops and door
doorknobs,
sure I mean bust out a little diffuser
and get a little citrus scent up in
there.
But do not use these as a replacement
for hygiene, social distancing, and common
sense. Next!
Okay moving on to salt therapy by Halosense. So salt therapy company
Halosense began promoting salt therapy as a means to protect against COVID 19
claiming that breathing in miniscule
salt particles clears the lungs of
"anything that shouldn't be in there".
That sounds really specific? Anyway, the
salt particles are allegedly antiviral
and with right preventive measures
through salt therapy they claim that
there is a slim chance you will catch
the disease. Oh yeah! That must be legit.
Now, this is not actually a new wellness
theory. Breathing in salty air, also known
as halo therapy, dates back to the
medieval era. Proponents of salt therapy
claim that salt cleanses the respiratory
system and can help to treat respiratory
conditions like asthma, bronchitis, and
allergies. However, studies on halo
therapy are highly mixed and
inconclusive. According to a 2014 review,
most studies on halo therapy for the
treatment of COPD, specifically, are
wildly flawed and respiratory experts
are highly skeptical of this technique
as it's not been rigorously studied
enough to recommend. Also, mind you, we're not in a situation where we should all
be running to the spa or a Wellness
Center to receive salt therapy. In fact,
all of these places have been shut down,
thank goodness,
along with other non-essential services.
Luckily, the products that we've
mentioned thus far have been flagged by
the FDA as misleading to the public and
were ordered to take immediate action to
correct these violations. The FDA is
continuously monitoring and warning
companies who sell these types of
fraudulent products that claim to
prevent, diagnose, treat, or cure COVID 19.
Twitter and Facebook have also begun
cracking down on their platforms for
misinformation including the promotion
of COVIS 19 related immunity boosting
products. If you're interested in a list
of warning letters issued by the FDA, I
will leave a link in the description
below if you want to stay up to date and
informed on these types of really
problematic products. But until then,
I would say just save your money and
breathe normal air at home. Next!
Next is Simply Inulin.
Now moving on to sketchy influencer
territory, let's talk about French
Wellness influencer IIngrid De La Mare-Kenny.
Now Ingrid promoted the product
Simply Inulin on her Instagram page as
powerful protection against COVID 19. In
a now-deleted post she claims that a
health professional in Monaco supposedly
recommended the use of the product
Simply Inulin as a means to support the
immune system and make it "bulletproof"
against the novel coronavirus. More than
just a random fan, Ingrid just so happens
to sell the product on her online store.
Uh, that is not suspicious at all? Now, for
those of you unfamiliar with inulin, it's
a type of prebiotic fibre which helps to
feed the beneficial bacteria in your gut.
In doing so, it encourages the growth of
healthy gut bacteria, like
Bifidobacterium and lactobacilli, which
in turn promotes healthy digestion. There
are also several known health benefits
of inulin fibre that go beyond
digestive health. Some studies have shown
that it may improve blood sugar control,
help relieve constipation, and has been
used as a weight loss aid by helping to
keep you fuller longer.
One thing that inulin is certainly not
effective towards is making the immune
system "bulletproof" towards COVID 19. Its
fibre folks, like, not a coveted N95 mask.
Now, though the research showing a link
between a healthy gut and immunity is
well documented, these findings pertain
to general immunity and not immunity
towards infection from COVID 19,
specifically. With the research COVID 19
still in its early stages, the role of
general immunity and the gut microbiome
in potentially combating the virus is
just not fully understood. It certainly
doesn't hurt to up your intake of inulin
fiber to support a healthy gut and
general immunity, but to make a
definitive statement that a particular
product will protect you against corona
virus is just so grossly wrong. If you're
interested in improving your gut health
to support general immunity, you can do
so by adding more probiotic rich foods
to your diet like yogurt, kimchi,
or sauerkraut. You can also
incorporate more prebiotic fibres into
your meals so foods like asparagus,
garlic, bananas, onions, or chicory root.
And doing all of that, of course, while
aiming towards eating more plant-based
foods that are rich in fiber and
antioxidants. You don't need a $30
supplement to do that. Next! And finally
let's talk about vitamin mega dosing.
Now you may or may not have heard about
members of the wellness community, such
as Peter Osborne and Andrew Saul,
recommending mega doses of antioxidants
like vitamin A, C, and D, as a means to
protect against COVID19. Not only are
these recommendations not supported by
the evidence, but they may actually be
extremely dangerous. These people are
recommending doses that are way beyond
the recommended amounts for each vitamin and they pose some serious health risks.
Vitamin C, for example, does have a role
in immunity and wound healing and can be
obtained from the diet by eating a
variety of fruits and vegetables. Because
vitamin C is water-soluble, it does not
get stored in the body and any excess is
excreted out in your pee. However, this
is mostly true for food sources of
vitamin C. Whereas, supplemental forms of
vitamin C are not excreted as easily
from the body leading to an increased
risk of toxicity. One 2019 review did find
that oral and IV high doses of vitamin C
treatment may reduce ICU stay by 8% and
shortened ventillation duration by 18.2%.
However, in practice, including early
experiments with COVID 19 patients,
doctors would never give these high
amounts orally. They would need to be
administered through an IV very
carefully monitored by a doctor.
The reason is that excess vitamin C
supplementation is not necessarily
benign. Excess vitamin C supplementation
can cause adverse health effects ranging
from digestive symptoms, like diarrhea
and nausea, to the development of kidney
stones and it may also lead to iron
overload which can be seriously damaging
for organs like the heart, liver, and
pancreas.
These adverse effects appear to occur
when people are taking vitamin C doses
just over 2,000 milligrams. And our
friends, Peter Osborne and Andrew Saul,
are recommending between 5,000 and
24,000 milligrams.
Folks, you may not need to go to the ER
for COVID but you'll be praying they
have a bed when your liver fails. As for
vitamin D, low levels of vitamin D have
been associated with respiratory disease
as well as viral respiratory infections
and decreased lung function. While we
don't have actual research on vitamin D
for COVID,  it does make sense that we
would want to keep our vitamin levels in
check especially considering the high
prevalence of vitamin D deficiency
worldwide. But as for high single doses, a
systematic review concluded that single
doses of vitamin D up to a hundred
thousand IUs may be effective at
improving vitamin D status to prevent
deficiency while under medical
supervision.
Mind you, these are findings not
recommendations and they pertain to a
single dose every three months not daily
dosages. Also, similar to vitamin C,
vitamin D also has potential risks from
high supplemental doses, including
elevated calcium levels, digestive
symptoms, dizziness, confusion, nausea,
vomiting, stomach pain, bone loss, and even kidney failure. Toxicity is also more
likely to occur in people taking high
dose supplements, as it is very unlikely
to reach high blood levels through diet
alone. Contrary to vitamin C, vitamin D is
fat soluble meaning it's stored in the
body fat and released into the
bloodstream slowly versus being excreted
immediately in the urine. Because we're
able to have vitamin D stores, this means
that the effects of vitamin D toxicity
may potentially last for several months
after you stop taking the supplements.
So the recommended daily amounts for adults is just 600 IUs compared to Peter
Osborne's recommendation of a 150,000 IUs of vitamin D.
I am pretty good at taking a lot of
supplements at once, but I would have to
take 250 vitamin D tablets per day just
to reach those recommendations.
That would work out to around $300 per week. Nope!
As for the risks of high supplemental
doses of vitamin A, they may include
vision changes, bone pain, skin changes,
respiratory infection, and possible
kidney and liver damage. Peter Osborne
recommends 7500 micrograms of vitamin A
which is more than eight times the
recommended daily amount of 700 to 900
micrograms for adults. So yeah, just
please don't. Bottom line, there is
absolutely nothing safe about taking
mega doses of vitamin supplements
without medical supervision as these can
cause some serious adverse health risks
which may even land you in the hospital.
And that is probably the last place you
want to be during a global pandemic. So,
please save your money, get your vitamins
mainly from food sources, take your usual
vitamin doses, and talk to a doctor or
dietitian before starting any new
supplements. Now I want to just conclude
with some general immunity tips. So the
big question, coronavirus or no
coronavirus, is there anything that we
can do naturally to support our immune
system for general health and well-being
according to the research? The answer is
yes there is. Though no one food or
supplement can prevent illness or
infection, you can always support your
immune system through a balanced diet
that includes adequate sources of
protein like lean meat, poultry, fish, eggs,
tofu, beans, legumes. Vitamin A from
sources like orange or yellow vegetables
and fruits, and dark leafy greens. Vitamin
C from things like citrus fruits and a
wide variety of vegetables. Vitamin E
from healthy fat sources like nuts and
oils. And zinc from whole grains, beans,
nuts, and animal protein. In addition to
supporting the immune system through
food, you can also support a healthy
immune system through lifestyle changes
by getting adequate sleep, exercising
regularly, and managing stress. Bottom
line, though "immunity boosting" sure is a
buzzword these days,
the reality is there
is currently no known cures or
preventative treatments for COVID 19.
Though research is still underway to
develop a vaccine, no food or product on
the market can promise immunity or
protection from this virus. So be
skeptical of anyone trying to sell or
promote a product that makes these
extreme and sensationalized promises.
Also, be skeptical of anyone who
simultaneously tries to sell these
themselves without giving alternative
product suggestions. Again, I want to
emphasize that while taking care of your
general health should always be a
priority, not just in a pandemic, the most
important things that you can
immediately do to protect yourself and
others is to wash your hands, avoid
touching your face, and practice social
distancing. Well folks, that is all for
this episode of The Ridiculist. Please
continue to stay safe and stay critical
of misinformation online, of course leave
me a comment below, like this video,
subscribe and I will see you next time
on Abbey's Kitchen. Bye!